hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about the distinctions between limpa
troughs and organic ropes now why is
this important this is important because
in biology organisms are often
classified based on various aspects of
their metabolism so for example
organisms can be classified on how they
get their energy so there are certain
organisms that would fall into the
classification of foto croaks who get
their energy from light and then other
organisms that don't get their energy
from life but who get their energy from
breaking down chemical compounds and
really releasing energy from this
chemical bond those are known as keema
trucks organisms can also be classified
according to where they get their carbon
source from so for example their
organisms they get their carbon from
carbon dioxide during carbon fixation
and those are called autotrophs and
there are other organisms that they get
their carbon by either absorbing or
ingesting and digesting organic matter
and those would be called heterotrophs
another way that these can sometimes be
described as autotrophs make their own
food heterotrophs have to eat it
somewhere else so that brings us to
talking about what do we mean by the
focus of today's video and that is with
the tropes and organic crops well we
talked about how organisms can be
classified based on how they acquire
energy or how they acquire carbon but
with the tropes vs. or gamma tropes are
distinguished based on their electron
donor during cellular respiration
so during cellular respiration there has
to be some kind of compound that donates
electrons and then go down on Khan
transport chain to help generate ATP now
in with the tropes the compound used
that is the electron donor is an
inorganic compound and in situations
where the electron donor is an organic
compound we classify these organisms as
organic drugs and you should also be
aware that these various prefixes can be
combined for example we can talk about
certain groups of organisms that are
photo lit though autotrophs so all
plants are photo let though honor tropes
what this means is that they get their
energy from light they get their carbon
from carbon dioxide so carbon fixation
and then they get their electron donor
is an inorganic compound all animals on
the other hand are kimo organo
heterotrophs this means that animals get
their energy from chemical bonds in our
carbon from absorbing and ingesting
other organic materials and then that
organic compound the electron donor is
an organic compound so that is how you
would combine these prefixes to discuss
the various characteristics of different
organism all metabolisms keep in mind
that there are that all limit ropes
every length of rope is a type of
bacterium like organic ropes include
many bacteria but also include plants
and animals and
organisms with which we are familiar if
you're interested in learning more about
some of these topics I have a couple of
other videos that you should check out
one is about these four classifications
so photo tropes came at Rose autotrophs
and heterotrophs if you're interested in
learning more about those check out my
video on that topic and then if you are
interested in learning a bit more about
this cellular respiration process then I
also have a video that will introduce
you to cellular respiration so check
those out and thanks for watching and I
hope to see you again soon bye